Goodness.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
am
the author tells us continuing in the
subject in the topic of alus bathing.
The author tells us that
it is permissible for a couple to bathe
together
as the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
was narrated to have bathed with his
wife
as she has narrated and this narration
is in Bkari Muslim.
Now we have taken the bare minimum of
which is
which is articulated by way of the
pillars of bathing and we went into the
most or the most complete of
and now we are going to discuss us the
various types of
which are preferred the various types of
preferred.
Now we've mentioned there are how many
types of obligatory?
Five types of obligatory, right? Number
one,
janaba. Number two,
huh?
Well, that's janaba. Yes.
Or actually, no, you're correct.
Intercourse.
You know even if a person
intercourse that is correct. Number
three
where we'll miss we're missing one there
before that.
Number three
when someone
[Arabic recitation]
is after menration and postpartum. And
number five
huh?
death. No, you you're you're bathed in
death.
Friday. Very good. So those are five
types of obligatory.
Are there other times when it is part
of the rights of Islam to bathe? Yes,
those are going to be now listed by the
author in the form of
toba the preferred times for a person to
make.
The author here mentions
eight
instances
in which it is preferred for a person to
make in which it is preferred for a
person to make.
Number one,
[Silence]
The first type he mentions here is
making
after
each or upon each time of
intercourse. We've mentioned before that
if a person has intercourse and then
wishes to have intercourse a second time
that the person it is the sunnah for him
to make right the prophet sallall.aii
am said.
And so he commanded that a person make
well on occasion rather than just making
he would make entirely
[Silence]
We have a narration here that the author
cites on the authority of that the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
had or frequented
the each of his wives in intercourse on
a single night.
And each time he would bathe at each
house that or each home of his wives
that he would be at. And so Abu Raf and
Abu Raf is one of the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam servants
he said oh messenger of Allah why don't
you just bathe all of them into one
at the end he said this is pure and
better and cleaner this narration has
been collected by Abu D so here we have
that this is
the second
that the woman who is experiencing
bathe for each prayer that she makes.
Now what is alhaba? This is going to
take us into an issue that we are going
to
expound upon at a later chapter in
the chapters regarding menration.
However, alaba
essentially is that a woman have her
menstrual cycle
and the menstrual cycle completes its
turn but then she continues to have
bleeding or spotting that is not of
menstrual blood. This is a very
important point here that it is not of
menstrual blood. The prophet sallall.aii
He identifies menstrual blood. He says
[Silence]
he identifies menstrual blood as being
dark in color and having an odor, a very
distinct smell. In another wording, it
is being dark in color and known to
women. They know the difference between
what is menration and what ishaba. Now
is not dark colored menration anymore.
This is that the menration has run its
course. However, now we have regular
blood. We know what regular blood looks
like. It is bright. It is thin. It is
very distinguished from something a
menstrual blood. It's even very
distinguished from blood that goes
through the digestive system. And so
this regular blood, this bright red
blood starts to come and it continues to
come and it is connected to her cycle.
This is called a dhaba.
She is no longer in a state of hay
in this.
But because of the constant breaking of
wudoo,
she is permitted to join the prayers and
she has some allowances that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam has given
her due to this very particular set
of circumstances.
But the best she can do, what is
preferred and what is best is to bathe
for each prayer until it runs its
course. But obviously if it is a very
long thing or if it's drawn out or if it
consistently happens multiple months,
then this can become very burdensome. So
it is relaxed from obligatory
bathing to preferred
bathing. And what is obligatory is woo
for each salah. Right? So the second
type and when we get to the chapters of
menration
we're not going to gloss over them
inshallah. We're going to go into
detail.
You say sh we do not menrate and I will
say yes I should hope so. However, not
one of us has been picked and plucked
off of a tree without coming from a
woman having in our homes woman
living with women and it is your
responsibility to teach your women. Let
me tell you something. If your women,
whoever of your women is under your
guidance and protection,
namely wife, daughter, sister, if she is
under your care, etc. If they make a
mistake in their religion, you will be
held accountable for it.
I will be held accountable for it
because it is our responsibility
to bring this knowledge home. Now many
of us may assume that our daughters, our
wives, our sisters are learning on their
own, right? They are literate. They can
access the internet. Not good enough.
And second of all, the worst thing you
can do for someone you are responsible
for is let them roam free on the
internet. That is a death sentence.
I would a person the the the
famously said I one of them said I would
rather find my son in a bar
than to find him at the feet of an
innovator learning.
Why?
Well, because when he's at that bar, he
knows and everyone knows that this is
haram and there's no excuse for it. And
my nephs just overtook me. But
innovation,
how is a person going to distinguish
innovation from sunnah? When are they
ever going to repent from innovation?
And the prophet Sam
said,
The innovator's
actions will not be accepted until he
repents from his innovation. Is a very
serious thing. And the last thing you
want is to have yourself,
let alone those whom you are responsible
for,
have the people of innovation, sink
their teeth into them, right? And teach
them all kinds of things. They'll teach
them all kinds of things. And one of the
worst things that a person can learn
from innovation is the arguments of
innovators
because their arguments were butchered
and buried by the scholars of of Islam
throughout the ages. However, it takes a
scholar to slaughter those innovations.
And when they are resurrected and
brought back, the people who are most
susceptible to this virus, to this
contagion, to this brain parasite are
the people that do not have the armor
and the artillery and the and the
weaponry of knowledge. They are not fit
to be able to head this off. So we're
going to study all things and especially
things that apply to our
most vulnerable i.e. our women and our
children.
[Silence]
Wait.